do you know that my first concert was
Twisted Sister I did not know that 1986
you did two nights at Hammer Smith OD
wow and uh my dad had me hoisted up I'm
sitting on my dad's shoulders like just
rocking out to Twisted Sister and like
one of the ushers saw this little kid I
was 11 I'm on my dad's shoulders the
Usher say come on come on let me Usher
you up to the front that user took me up
and you slapped me a high five from the
stage for sure I see a 11-year-old kid
on his father's shoulders I'm like cuz
I'm already a dad at that point so my
kid is already four years old 5 years
old I'm totally getting this young dad
with his kid bringing him to a show so
that was deliberate it was not an
accident I want you to know that that
was really special man that's awesome
changed the course of his life